[音楽]
ご紹介ありがとうございます大阪工業大学
講師の松井と申します本日はですね
嫌なロボットには何ができるかという
テーマでお話をさせていただきたいと思い
ますはいでキーワードを
嫌なロボットとさせていただきましたはい
具体的に超えれるどんなロボットでしょう
かちょっといくつかお見せしたいと思い
ますはいまずこちらロボットの動画をお
見せしたいと思います
6+4
カブトムシですはいロボットがなんか
計算をしているんですけどなんか変なこと
言ってますよねでもう一つちょっと例を
致します今度はバーチャルエージェント
ですちょっとバーチャルエージェントが
喋っているという動画です
はじめまして私はメイです皆さんに
素敵な旅行を推薦するお仕事をしています
寒い日が続いていますがいかがお過ごし
でしょうか
ちなみに私は
晴れの日と雨の日では
晴れの日の方が好きですなぜなら
宅配ピザが早く届くからです皆さんは
いかがですかはいこれもですね自己紹介を
しているんですけれどもなんか変なこと
言ってますよねはいこのなんかこのなんか
変な感じをちょっとなんかこれこの話題で
は嫌なという風に定義したいと思います
じゃあこんなロボットとか
バーチャルエージェントはなぜ
嫌だと思うのか
これはロボットなのに
我々の予想を裏切るからだと思われます
はいでですね皆さんはこんなロボットは
使い物にならないというふうに思われるか
もしれませんけれども実は我々がやった
実験ではこういう風なさっきお見せした
ような一見嫌なロボットとかバーチャル
エージェントの方が実はより人間から
信頼されるという結果が得られてますこれ
何ででしょうかということをちょっと今日
はお話したいと思いますはいでですねあの
ちょっとまあ難しいことはを使わせて
もらえますけれども
我々はロボットとかAIとかっていうのは
まあ
完全にまあ人間のコントロールカーにある
もの
完全に人間の予測通りに動くものだと思う
わけですでロボットとかに限らず
我々はまあだいたいのものは予測可能な
ものだというふうに捉えて
日々まあ生活してますでこういう世界観を
自然
科学的世界観とここではちょっと呼びたい
と思いますこれは全ての事象ははモデル化
ができて単純化できるというような見方
ですで
果たしてこういう見方が
常に正しいのかどうかということを
ちょっと今日は皆さんと考えていきたいと
思いますはいさてですねちょっとあの話題
を変えますけれども私の
研究分野はヒューマンエージェント
インタラクションという名前ですで頭文字
にとってHAIなんていう風に言われる
ことも結構多いですおそらくこれほとんど
の方が初めて聞くと思いますこれをですね
人間と何らかのものとのインタラクション
というぐらいの意味ですインタラクション
というのは相互作用という意味ですね言葉
による相互作用とかあるいは身振り手振り
とか
視線なんかも含めたそういう非言語的な
ものを含めた相互作用のことを
インタラクションというふうに言います
はいでですねヒューマンエージェント
インタラクションにおいては人間と例えば
ロボットであるとかあるいは人間と
コンピューター人間と機械などの
インタラクションというのをまあ工学的に
考えていくという分野ですさらにはそう
いう人間と人工物とのインタラクションを
考えるために人間同士とあるとか人間と
動物のインタラクションというものも考え
ていく
研究対象にしていますはいさてですねここ
で
もう一つ内部と外部っていう概念を
導入したいと思います内部っていうのは
私たちの想定内の世界です私たちが完全に
予想できる
範囲の世界これを内部という風に言いたい
と思いますはい
我々はだいたい日々いろんなことを予測し
ながら生きてるわけですね例えば雨が雨が
降ったら
濡れるなとかあの人はなんかちょっと顔が
しかめずらしてるから怒ってるなとかいう
ことを
我々はそういうふうに何々だったら何々
みたいなそういうモデルを心の中みんな
持ってるわけですねこれをまあ心理学では
メンタルモデルなんていう風に言ったりし
ますはいでちょっとモテるって言葉をもう
ちょっと詳しく言っておくとこれは現実
世界のものを分析するために単純化して
表現したものという意味です例えば
有名なもので
ニュートンの運動方程式これは自然界を
モデル化したものですね
あとさっきさっきあの紹介した明太モデル
だったりあとヒューマンエージェント
インタラクションでは他者をモデル化し
ますこれを他社モデルと言いますはいで
他社モデルっていうのは何かと言ったら
さっきお話したようにこの人は今こういう
表情してるからこういう感情だとかこの人
はこういうこと言ってるからこういう風に
思ってるとかいうようなモデルこれをまあ
我々はこういうモデルを作って他者を理解
しているという風にヒューマン
エージェントインタラクションではまあ
捉えるわけですでそれが本当に他者を理解
するための方法として
妥当かどうかということについてちょっと
私は結構疑問に思ってるんですねはい
例えばあるロボットは他社モデルとして
喜怒哀楽の4つの感情を持ってるとします
そうするとこのロボットはその喜怒哀楽の
どれにも当てはまらないようなちょっと
複雑な感情の人っていうものは
理解できないということになりますつまり
モデルにないものっていうのは理解でき
ないとでそういう自分のモデル街つまり
言い換えたら自分の予測の外にあるものと
いうものは
理解できないので
そのモデルの外から持ってくる必要がある
でこのモデルの外のものを外部という風に
言いたいと思います
はいで私がちょっと強調したいのは他社と
いうのは本質的に外部だということです
他者モデルを作って
完全にモデル化して
完全に内部化して
捉えようとしても他者というのは本質的に
常に
我々の予測っていうものを裏切る自分の
我々の予想というものの範囲から
範囲出るというような
そういう可能性を常に持ってますつまり
予測できないことこそが他社の本質である
というふうに私は思いますはいで一方で
繰り返すようにヒューマンエージェント
インタラクションにおける他社モデルと
いうのは他者を内部化する試みです
果たしてこれがこれによって例えば
ロボットが他者を理解することができるか
どうできるかどうかということですねはい
例えばこのロボットは会社モデルとして
感情と医師と対象っていう3つの変数を
持ってるとしましょうでこの3つの変数を
入力すると何
らかの予測この人は遊びに行こうとして
いるみたいな予測を出すこういう
単純な他社モデルですけれども例えばこの
ロボットは変数3つしかないですから
例えばそれ
以外のこの3つ以外の変数例えば今日は
予定が予定が
埋まってるとか予定がある仕事がある
とかいうことは入力できないわけですねで
だから実際にはこの人は予定があるから
遊びには行けないんだけれどもそれを学校
のロボットには理解できないからこの人
遊びに行くという風に判断しちゃうと他社
モデルっていうのは
常にこういう限界を持ってますこれを変数
の数をいくら増やしても一緒で
常にそのモデルからはみ出る可能性がある
というわけですねはいでここでちょっと
冒頭でお見せしたああいうロボット
バーチャルエージェントというのはいかに
してそれその限界を超えようとしているの
かをお話ししますまず最初でお見せした
ロボットの例5+6はカブトムシっていう
なんか変なこと言ってましたけれども
我々は5+6はって聞いたら5
+6はって聞いたら算数の計算っていう
文脈を想定するわけですねで5+6は11
って言われたらあってるだとか5+6は
10って言われたら間違ってるなとかって
いう風に判断しますけれどもそれは
あくまでも
算数の計算っていう文脈内の話なわけです
しかしここでカブトムシとか言われたら
それはもう算数の
計算って文脈に収まりませんから
そのロボットを理解するためにはもう別の
文脈っていうもの持ってくる必要があると
でこの別の文脈っていうものはもともとの
ロボットの発話にはなかったものですから
もう外部という風なものになるわけです
2つ目の例ですねあれは私は晴れが好き
ですなぜなら
宅配ピザが早く届くからですというこの2
つの間がよくわかんないですねこの2つの
間
矛盾してるとは言えないけれども
理由がよくわからないとなので聞いてる人
っていうのはその間を
埋めようとしますでその間を埋めるために
操縦されるものこれが会話に明示されてい
ない外部なわけですねで単純に大事な
ことっていうのはこういう外部を
召喚するロボットバーチャルエージェント
というのは人間の信頼を
獲得しますということですはいじゃあなん
でそういうロボットが
信頼されるかということちょっと考えてみ
ましょう最初のお話したように我々は
直感的には自然
科学的な世界観に従って生きているという
ふうに思ってますまあこれはこの世界観は
すべての事象っていうのは単純化して
モデル化できるようであるとかあるいは
全ての事象は
因果関係でつながっていて何か起きたら
何か原因があるというような世界観です
こういうのは当然だと思ってる人も多い
でしょうけれどもこれはあくまでも一つの
使い方に過ぎないわけですねでじゃあ他に
どんな世界観が世界観があるかと言ったら
全近代
昔であれば
紙とかお化けとか妖怪っていう
エージェントがいたわけですいたというか
想定されていたわけですでそれ
らっていうのは現実世界の因果関係の外に
あるものつまり外部だったわけですねそう
いう外部にエージェントを設定していたで
それによって何が良かったかというとそれ
によって
内部の世界の
矛盾とか不都合な不都合なことの説明って
いうのを神とか
妖怪っていうものにまあ請け負ってもらっ
てたわけですねで現在ではもう神とか妖怪
っていうものをリアリティというものは
もうないわけですから実はロボットとか
AIっていうのはその神とか妖怪みたいな
外部のエージェントに
するべきではないかというふうに私は考え
てますはいそもそも
我々本当に自然科学的な世界観だけで生き
てるんでしょうかね例えば他社と節制する
時に他者をいちいちモデル化して
インダクションしているということを我々
普段やってるでしょうか
よく考えてみたらこんなことは我々やって
ないですね
常に他者というものは外部であるという
ことは前提としてつまり他者が自分の予測
どおりに従わないことっていうのは
織り込んだ上で
常に外部と向き合うようにして他社と
接してるはずですこれが我々は本当はこう
いうことを常にやってるわけですねそれが
ロボットを作るとかなっちゃうと
他社モデルとかっていう話になっちゃうと
そこはちょっとおかしいよねっていうふう
に私は私が思ってるわけですはいで
ちょっと最初の最初の話題に戻ってまあ
ああいうロ嫌だった感じる理由っていうの
はロボットを内部だと思ってるから
ロボットがモデルに合わない行動した時に
嫌だと感じるのが原因だと思われます
しかしそもそもロボットも外部ではないか
他者ではないかという風に考えればそう
いう予測不可能性っていうものは嫌だと
いう感じではなくてよりポジティブな感じ
に
転換するわけですはいで私がちょっと強調
したいことっていうのは全てをモデル化
する必要はないってことですね先ほども
申し上げたように我々は他社と他者と
向き合う時に他者を
必ずしもモデル化してるわけではありませ
んそうじゃなくてその場その場でもう
アドリブ的にその場その場で出てくる他者
というものと
即興的にインタラクションをしていると
いうのが本来の姿だと思われます
はいで
こういうようなつまり
嫌なものを考えるというのは
我々の
想定している世界内部から自由になること
です
我々の持っているモデルというものから
自由に考えることが可能になるそういう
意味で嫌なロボットというものを
私は考えていきたいというふうに思って
ます
ありがとうございました
[拍手]